[S01] 嗯，在今天咱们正式开始之前，我想先问你，也就是正在听节目的你一个问题
[S01] 就是上一次你看到一个那种太平洋这种规模，而且几乎毫无差错的这种人造物是什么时候？
[S02] 这个问题其实很有意思。
[S02] 著名的计算机科学家艾伦凯，他以前提过一个特别引人深思的观念。
[S02] 他说，现在的人们往往把互联网看作是一种，呃，就像太平洋一样的自然资源，就好像它本来就在那里一样。
[S01] 对，觉得理所当然。
[S02] 没错，但实际上它是人类历史上构建过的最庞大，
[S02] 结构也是最精密，同时也可以说是最不可思议的一台机器。
[S01] 确实是这样，而且这台巨大的机器，它甚至没有图纸，也没有什么所谓的中心控制室，但它就是支撑着全球的经济啊，文化，还有你每天的这种数字生活。
[S02] 是的。
[S01] 所以在今天的深度探索中呢，
[S01] 我们的任务就是要带你解码，隐藏在这些日常APP页面和按钮背后的隐形力量。
[S02] 嗯，也就是那些看不见的部分。
[S01] 对，我们今天的核心资料是来自软件工程领域的一本绝对的经典，《设计数据密集型应用》，也就是大家常说的DDIA 这本书的第二章。
[S02] 也就是系统架构的内功心法。
[S01] 没错，我们今天不聊那些表面上眼花缭乱的前端功能，我们要聊的是决定一个软件到底是死是活的关键。呃，也就是非功能性需求，包括性能、可靠性、可伸缩性，还有可维护性。
[S02] 因为你想啊，平时你每天滑动屏幕或者点按钮的时候，你看到的其实只是功能，但功能得以存在的那个大前提是，
[S02] 系统在极端压力下不能崩溃。
[S01] 太真实了。如果一个应用慢的让你简直失去耐心，或者说在双十一结账的时候，它直接给你宕机了，那你功能再多再酷炫也等于零，对吧？
[S02] 绝对的。这就是为什么非功能性需求往往比功能本身更致命。
[S01] 好吧，那让我们把这个问题拆解开来看。
[S01] 概念听起来可能有点抽象，没关系，为了让你能直观地理解现代系统的这种复杂性，我们直接从一个你每天起床可能做的第一件事开始聊。
[S02] 比如刷社交网络的时间线。
[S01] 没错，比如打开X，也就是以前的推特。其实我们平时随便刷两下，背后是一个极其严苛的业务场景。
[S02] 这是一个绝佳的切入点。我们可以设想一下，一个拥有海量活跃用户的社交网络，它每天会产生大概超过五亿条帖子。
[S01] 五亿条，我的天。
[S02] 是的，平均下来每秒钟就是五千七百条新动态。那如果在突发新闻期间，
[S02] 呃，这个数字甚至会飙升到每秒十五万条。
[S01] 这流量太可怕了。
[S02] 对，然后关键是，当你打开APP的那一瞬间，首页必须立刻，注意是立刻，展示你关注的所有人最新发布的动态。
[S01] 嗯，如果按直觉来说的话，最简单的做法不就是拉取吗？
[S02] 你是说轮询那种方式啊？
[S01] 对啊，就是你打开APP，然后后台系统就去数据库里用SQL查一下，找出来说，诶，这个用户关注了哪些账号，然后把这些账号最近的帖子捞出来，按时间倒序排个版不就行了吗？听起来逻辑很通顺嘛。
[S02] 逻辑上确实很通顺，但是在推特这种量级下，这就变成一场灾难了。
[S01] 怎么说？
[S02] 假设现在有一千万人同时在线，
[S02] 系统要保证你在几秒内就看到最新的内容。这意味着每秒钟，
[S02] 系统可能会接到上百万次的刷新请求。
[S01] 嗯，然后呢？
[S02] 如果你关注了两百个人，那每一次刷新，
[S02] 系统就要去查这两百个人的数据。你算算看，底层数据库每秒要承受上亿次的随机读取。
[S01] 上亿次随机读取。
[S02] 没错，任何一种单一的数据集群都扛不住这种读取风暴，瞬间就会熔断。
[S01] 哇，这就好比我举个例子啊，就像好像我是个邮递员，这种拉取或者说轮询，就像是我每天去镇上每个人的家里敲门，问，诶，今天有给我的信吗？关键不仅是我在敲门，镇上一千万人同时都在疯狂敲邮局的门，问同一个问题。
[S02] 邮局的柜台人员根本查不过来。所以DDIA 这本书里提到的破局点其实是一波反向操作。
[S01] 就是改成推送。
[S02] 对，也就是系统架构里常说的物化视图，或者是扇出 fan-out。
[S01] 展开说说这个扇出。
[S02] 就是系统不再傻傻的等你来查询了，而是在别人写入数据，也就是发帖的时候，提前把准备工作做好。
[S01] 哦，提前做准备。
[S02] 对，当有人发布新帖子，
[S02] 系统在后台就会直接把这条内容推送，插入到所有关注这个人的粉丝的个人时间线缓存里。
[S01] 也就是说，等我打开APP的时候，我的时间线其实早就已经拼好了。
[S02] 没错，早就预先计算好了。这时候读取操作就变成了一个极其轻量级的动作，瞬间就能完成。
[S01] 我明白了，就等于邮局预先在每个人的专属信箱里建好了一个投递队列，有人发信，
[S01] 邮递员马上就把信塞进所有粉丝的信箱里，等我去拿信的时候，打开信箱拿走就行了。
[S02] 这个比喻非常准确，这就是用后台写入的复杂和成本，去换取前端读取的极速体验。
[S01] 但是等等啊，我突然想到一个致命漏洞，普通人发信没问题，但如果发信的这个人，呃，比如说是贾斯丁比伯，或者那种拥有几千万上亿粉丝的超级名人呢？
[S02] 诶，你抓到重点了，这就是扇出机制遇到超级节点的翻车时刻。你想，
[S02] 一个拥有一亿粉丝的名人发了一条状态。
[S01] 那系统岂不是要去往一亿个人的信箱里疯狂塞信？
[S02] 对，这会消耗极其庞大的计算资源，不仅耗时特别长，还会导致整个后台的任务队列严重堵塞。那时候连带普通用户的帖子也会被卡得发不出去。
[S01] 把一封信复印一亿份，
[S01] 塞进一亿个信箱，这简直太蠢了。
[S01] 那这种极端情况到底怎么处理？总不能限制大V发帖吧。
[S02] 当然不能。所以现代架构里做的
[S02] 当然是采用一种混合模式。
[S01] 混合模式。
[S02] 对于这种超级大V，系统会把他们的帖子单独存储，根本不走扇出那个流程。
[S01] 那我怎么看到他们的帖子呢？
[S02] 当你打开你的个人信箱看普通信件的时候，
[S02] 系统会在那个瞬间把超级大V的新动态单独提取出来，
[S02] 跟你的普通信件进行一次实时的合并。
[S01] 哦，明白了，就相当于对于总统或者超级名人，
[S01] 邮局就不往每个人的信箱里塞信了，
[S01] 而是直接在广场的公告栏贴张大字报。我出门去信箱拿普通信件的时候，顺便抬头看一眼大字报，自己把两边信息拼起来。
[S02] 完美。这种在写入时做批量处理和读取时做实时合并的做法，其实就是架构设计中最核心的一个词，权衡。
[S01] 权衡，有舍有得。
[S02] 对，为了解决读取极度拥堵的问题，我们增加了后台投递的复杂性。而为了解决极端名人写入造成的拥堵，
[S02] 我们又在读取时加了一点点合并的逻辑。
[S01] 哇，这种为了追求极致速度而做出的复杂权衡，正好就引出了咱们评估系统的第一个核心维度，性能。
[S02] 性能确实是大家都非常关注的。
[S01] 对，
[S01] 咱们刚刚通过那个信箱和公告栏的机制，让系统的吞吐量上去了，看起来是变快了。但是这里才是真正有趣的地方。你看我之前查资料的时候，发现很多公司在外面吹嘘自己系统的平均响应时间只有两百毫秒什么的，其实这完全是个谎言，对吗？
[S02] 不仅是谎言，它还掩盖了极其糟糕的用户体验。
[S02] 平均值在评估性能时可以说是毫无意义的。
[S01] 怎么说？
[S02] 我们得先剥离它两个概念，延迟和响应时间。延迟仅仅是指一个请求在网络里潜伏，或者在服务器队列里排队等待处理的时间。
[S01] 那响应时间呢？
[S02] 响应时间是你作为用户盯着手机屏幕，从点击到看到结果等待的总时间，而导致响应时间剧烈波动的最大元凶就是排队延迟，业内管这个叫头部阻塞。
[S01] 头部阻塞？呃，就像是我在超市结账排队，
[S01] 平均每个人结账只要一分钟，但是我排的那条通道最前面那个大哥推了满满三车东西，还要用不同的信用卡分开结账，最后还要退货。
[S02] 对，
[S02] 遇到这种情况最绝望啊。
[S01] 是啊，就算我手里只拿了一瓶矿泉水，我的响应时间也会被硬生生拉长到半个小时。
[S02] 就是这个道理。这就是为什么看平均值骗人骗己，真正懂行的工程师看的一定是百分位点。
[S01] 比如P50，P九十五这些。
[S02] 对，中位数P50只能代表一半人。高级工程师看P95，P99，甚至P99.9，意思是每一千个请求里最慢的一个。
[S01] 听说亚马逊就对这个P99.9特别敏感。
[S02] 极其敏感。你想想在电商系统里，哪种用户的响应时间最慢？
[S01] 呃，买东西最多的。
[S02] 没错，往往是那些购买力最丰富，购物车里塞满了几十件商品，账户逻辑最复杂的人。这些人恰恰是购买力最强的高价值客户啊。
[S01] 哎，这里我就必须要提出一点质疑了。我承认这些人是高价值客户，但是为了这仅仅百分之零点一的极端情况，去投入极其巨大的工程优化架构，真的值得吗？
[S02] 你觉得不值得。
[S01] 这就好比为了让最偏远山区里的最后一个人能喝到依云矿泉水，硬生生修了一条高铁过去，这算不算过度工程啊。
[S02] 这是一个非常普遍的直觉之一。但在现代微服务架构下，有个很可怕的乘数效应，你可能忽略了。
[S01] 什么效应？
[S02] 叫做尾部延迟放大。你想想现代网页是怎么工作的？当你打开一个电商首页，后台可不是一台服务器在干活，它同时会向推荐系统、广告系统、库存、物流等等发送几十上百个并行请求。
[S01] 等等，既然是并行的，
[S01] 那不应该是一起加载吗？哪个服务慢了，先不管它，显示其他的不就好了。
[S02] 理想中是这样，但现实里前端往往需要等待这几个核心服务全部返回数据，
[S02] 才能拼接完成渲染。
[S01] 哦，木桶效应。
[S02] 假设你有一个微服务，它的P99延迟很高，就是说一百次调用里有一次非常慢。那当你渲染一个页面需要调用一百个不同的后台服务时，只要其中有任何一个服务撞上了那百分之一的慢概率，你整个页面的响应就被拖垮了。
[S01] 我算算，就意味着原本只有百分之一的人遇到的卡顿，在一百个微服务的叠加下。
[S02] 从概率上算，会导致超过百分之六十的普通用户都会经历这种糟糕的慢加载。
[S01] 哇，这就完全解释得通了。那百分之零点一的慢速根本不是孤立的，它像病毒一样传染了整个系统。而且我记得雅虎以前有个经典研究，说响应时间哪怕只慢了一点二五秒，用户的点击率就会暴跌百分之二十到三十。
[S02] 不仅是流失用户，
[S02] 当系统变慢，用户盯着那个转圈的加载图标失去耐心的时候，他们会做什么？
[S01] 本能的疯狂点击刷新啊。
[S02] 对，原本系统已经过载，
[S02] 处理不过来了，用户和客户端还在不断重发请求，这会引发重试风暴，
[S02] 系统就会陷入亚稳态故障，彻底崩溃。
[S01] 所以为了让系统快，我们弄了那么多推拉机制，那么多微服务，但这些复杂性本身恰恰又成了脆弱的根源。这就把我们推向了评估系统的第二大支柱了，可靠性。
[S02] 性能和可靠性确实是绑在一起的。
[S01] 是啊，当我们在谈论性能极限的时候，其实就是在故障的边缘疯狂试探嘛。
[S02] 没错，
[S02] 其实讨论可靠性，我们要先明确两个词的区别，故障也就是 fault和失效，也就是 failure。
[S01] 这两个不是一回事儿吗？
[S03] 不完全是。故障是指系统里某一个单一的组件坏了，比如一台服务器的网卡烧了，而失效是指整个系统彻底挂了，没办法给用户提供服务了。
[S01] 懂了，这就像故障就好比是我的汽车在路上爆胎了，而失效呢就是因为爆胎导致我错过了极其重要的国际航班。
[S03] 对，所谓容错，就是哪怕有故障发生，也就是就算爆胎了，
[S03] 系统也不能失效。我们要造个备胎嘛。
[S01] 防患于未然。
[S03] 因为在大规模系统里，硬件故障从来都不是会不会发生的问题，
[S03] 而是每天发生多少次。
[S01] 每天？
[S03] 硬盘的年故障率大概在百分之二到百分之五。如果你有一个一万块硬盘的机房，
[S03] 按统计学算，每天都有一块硬盘直接寿终正寝。
[S01] 这还不算其他的硬件问题。
[S03] 是的，除了这种正常的损坏，还有那些防不胜防的物理干扰，比如宇宙射线。
[S01] 等等，宇宙射线，你这听起来像是在拍科幻电影啊。
[S03] 这可是真实的工程梦魇。来自宇宙深处的高能粒子穿透大气层，刚好击穿了你服务器的内存硅片，这种微小的电荷改变就会导致比特翻转。
[S01] 比特翻转，就是本来是零的数据，被射线一击变成一了。
[S03] 没错，毫无征兆的数据损坏，如果没有校验机制，
[S03] 后果不堪设想。
[S01] 硬件的死法真是千奇百怪啊。不过我看书里说，硬件故障通常都是孤立的对吧？你这台机器被射线打中了，旁边的机器其实没啥事。真正具有毁灭性连带效应的是软件故障。
[S03] 对，
[S03] 软件故障也有高度的相关性。机房里几千台服务器跑的往往是同一套代码。如果里面有个BUG,那就是一个超级定时炸弹。
[S01] 比如呢？
[S03] 比如二零一二年极其著名的闰秒BUG,仅仅一位全球标准时间多出了一秒，
[S03] Linux内核里的一个小逻辑被异常触发，结果是大量运行Java的应用在同一时刻集体死锁。
[S01] 没有任何硬件坏掉。
[S03] 没有，硬件全都是好的，但整个系统瞬间全面瘫痪。
[S01] 太吓人了。但说句话，
[S01] 咱们诚实一点，在绝大多数系统里，
[S01] 最大的变数既不是硬件，
[S01] 也不是代码里的潜伏BUG,而是每天敲键盘的人类吧。
[S03] 研究发现，大概有百分之十到二十五的停机是由硬件引起的，但最大的杀手其实是运维人员的一次配置变更，就是人为错误。
[S01] 这让我想起那个让人后背发凉的英国邮局Horizon丑闻。
[S02] 那确实是个巨大的灾难。
[S01] 是啊，你想想看，那个系统有严重的软件缺陷，不断地生成错误的账目短缺数据，但当时的法律系统居然默认计算机是不会错的，结果导致几百名无辜的邮局局长被误判盗窃、破产甚至入狱。这说明软件不可靠是会真实的摧毁人生。你想想，如果那是你从小到大的家庭云相册，因为某个BUG瞬间全没了，那是什么感觉？
[S02] 所以在系统工程里，
[S02] 我们现在极其强调无责备的售后分析文化，也就是blameless postmortems出事儿了，不要去指责那个敲错命令的倒霉蛋，因为人就是会犯错。
[S01] 靠人是靠不住的。
[S02] 既然硬件、软件，甚至人类都会不可避免地犯错出故障，那我们该怎么做才能保证整个系统不失效呢？这就引出了像Netflix这样的巨头公司做了一个反直觉的做法。
[S01] 叫混沌工程，对吧？我听过，据说他们搞了个叫Chaos Monkey 的程序，居然在工作日的大白天随机去关掉生产环境里的服务器，这不是吃饱了撑的自己找死吗？
[S02] 这背后的机制其实跟打疫苗一模一样，疫苗不就是往你身体里注射微量可控的病毒去激发免疫系统吗？
[S01] 哎，这个比喻绝了。
[S02] 你在系统里写了灾难恢复代码，但是三年都没用过，
[S02] 真出事儿了，你怎么知道它还能不能跑？混沌工程就是通过持续制造小故障去强制系统演练，保证大灾难来的时候，免疫系统是活着的。
[S01] 这招真的狠，
[S01] 但是有效。
[S01] 好，
[S01] 那么好消息来了，你的系统现在不仅快如闪电，而且通过了混沌工程的毒打，坚如磐石。然后你的产品突然爆火了，用户量激增，原来完美的系统现在开始不堪重负了，这就到了第四大支柱，可伸缩性。
[S02] 应对伸缩性，最怕的就是瞎折腾。第一步必须得是去描述负载。
[S01] 描述负载。
[S02] 对，你是并发用户突然变多了吗？还是大家发帖子变猛了，导致每秒写入多了。
[S02] 应对每秒十万次极小的请求和应对每分钟三次2GB 大文件的请求，这是两种完全不同的架构。
[S01] 传统应对负载的方法，是不是就是纵向伸缩，也就是scaling up去买更贵的超级计算机，
[S01] 加内存、加 CPU？
[S02] 过去是这样，但那种共享内存的超级计算机成本是非线性爆炸的。现在主流的做法是横向伸缩scaling out.
[S01] 也就是把数据分片铺到一大堆极其便宜的普通服务器上，所谓的无共享架构。
[S02] 理论上横向伸缩无限好，但真正在工程落地时，到处都是泥沼，数据一分片，原本极其简单的跨表查询，现在变成了跨越内网络的分布式事务，你得处理网络延迟，还得搞定数据脑裂问题。
[S01] 哎，那我就不明白了，既然横向扩展这么痛苦，
[S01] 长痛不如短痛嘛。如果我是一个初创公司的CTO,知道未来肯定要横向扩展的。我为什么不从第一天起就直接照抄谷歌的微服务和无共享架构呢？
[S02] 这是一个极其常见的，也非常致命的创业陷阱。
[S01] 为什么？直接一步到位不好吗？
[S02] 过早优化是万恶之源呐。你盲目追求大厂的伸缩性，你不仅享受不到大厂的红利，反而还得提前去交高昂的分布式系统税。
[S01] 分布式系统税。
[S02] 比如服务间通信的网络延迟啊，
[S02] 复杂的要命的故障排查啊。对于一家初创公司，如果产品死在没找到市场需求上，那你搞的那套堪比谷歌的完美架构，就全成了昂贵的陪葬品。
[S01] 真是太真实啊，活下来才是第一位的。
[S02] 是的，在早期，
[S02] 五个模块组成的单体应用，通常比五十个微服务更简单，
[S02] 掉头也更灵活。
[S01] 确实，没有流量的时候操心谷歌级别的并发，
[S01] 属于自作多情了。那假设我们真的熬过了流量爆发，活下来了，这系统跑了好几年了，
[S01] 你会发现原来一开始写代码的那几个月根本算不上什么成本，漫长的维护期才是真正的黑洞。
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 一个活得够久的成功系统，
[S01] 最终都会变成所谓的遗留系统。这也就是我们的第五个支柱，
[S01] 可维护性。
[S02] 业界的数据很明确，
[S02] 软件生命周期绝大部分的成本都在维护阶段。比如修BUG啊，支持新场景啊，还有还技术债。
[S01] 对，把系统搞得太复杂，就像是用高利贷买了一栋豪宅，一开始住得很爽，确实很气派，但是你每天都要付高昂的技术债利息。
[S02] 也就是所谓的偶发复杂性。
[S01] 没错，今天改一个功能，明天弄坏了三个毫无关系的地方。最后这种系统就会变成业内常说的大泥团Big Ball of Mud谁都不敢碰。
[S02] 所以管理复杂度的终极武器是什么？只有一个，就是抽象。
[S01] 这个词儿有点虚，到底什么是抽象？
[S02] 举个最底层的例子，硬盘在底层其实就是一堆高速旋转的磁性金属盘，有个机械臂带着磁头在上面找扇区。
[S01] 对，听着就很硬核。
[S02] 如果你每次查数据都得自己写代码去控制那个机械臂，
[S02] 移动到几号扇区读取电压信号，那人类根本不可能开发出今天的互联网应用。
[S01] 那肯定是疯了。
[S02] 所以有了SQL 语言嘛，SQL 隐藏了底层所有的并发呀、磁盘结构啊，这些细节你只要用人类逻辑告诉他我要什么数据就行了，这就是抽象的力量。
[S01] 明白了，
[S01] 就就好像汽车的方向盘，我不需要懂发动机是怎么喷油的，火花塞是怎么点火的，我只要转动方向盘，车就能转弯，这就叫抽象。
[S02] 对，设计时的每一个决定，建立的每一个清晰模型，
[S02] 其实都是在给未来的维护者写信，而那个人很可能就是半年后已经把细节忘得一干二净的你自己。
[S01] 哇，说得太好了。
[S01] 那总结一下咱们今天的旅程，
[S01] 从一条简单的社交网络帖子出发，
[S01] 我们看透了推送和扇出的权衡，然后拆穿了平均响应时间的谎言，看到了微服务下尾部延迟放大的威力。
[S02] 我们还看到了软硬件故障的必然性，以及用混沌工程来抵抗灾难。
[S01] 没错，
[S01] 我们也聊了，
[S01] 别一开始就抄谷歌的作业，明白了伸缩性的权衡。最后，
[S01] 我们探讨了用抽象这个武器去抵抗系统变成大泥团的宿命。
[S02] 这些就是支撑现在数字世界的四大支柱。
[S01] 所以下次当你用手机刷网页，
[S01] 遇到卡顿在那儿转菊花的时候，也许你可以换个角度想一想，这背后究竟是你不小心撞上了那P99的尾部延迟，还是说某台远在天边的云服务器，刚好被来自宇宙深处的一束高能射线击穿了内存。
[S02] 这确实是一种很浪漫又很写实的看待数字世界的方式。
[S01] 是的，那在今天节目的最后呢，我想给你，
[S01] 对，就是正在听的你留下一个书中提到，
[S01] 我们还没深挖，但特别值得反思的深刻思想，叫做自动化的讽刺。
[S02] Ironies of Automation.
[S01] 没错，你看，为了极致的性能和可靠性，
[S01] 我们引进了越来越高级的自动化系统来代替人工操作。可是自动化程度越高，机器自己处理的故障就越多，人类在平时就越没有机会介入。
[S02] 也就是说，人类对这个系统的手感会越来越生疏。
[S01] 对，那一旦有一天，这个庞大的系统发生了一次机器搞不定的史诗级大崩溃，那些早就习惯了袖手旁观，甚至根本不懂底层细节的人类，真的还有能力去拯救它吗？
[S02] 我们创造了极度复杂的工具，最后反而在工具面前变成了无助的旁观者。
[S01] 这是个让人后背发凉的问题，期待你带着这个疑问去重新审视你工作和生活里遇到的那些复杂系统吧。非常感谢你加入这次知识深度探索，
[S01] 我们下次再见。